first let me introduce you to the
directors and the producer so to my left
Lisa mulot oh sorry Mamont has directed
and edited award-winning
documentaries about this the American
southwest in recent years including the
cleaners and solad she has also focused
on stories about education her
award-winning film schools out has been
an integral part of the movement for
providing outdoor education for young
children children and her short film
teaching in Arizona is an inside look at
the teaching crisis in the state a
recent Fullbright scholar she teaches
courses at at the James E Rogers school
of law at the University of Arizona
where she has worked with the
immigration law clinic for the past four
years and has also taught in the UA
human rights practice graduate program
um next to her is um Jeff Miz who is a
producer co-director and
cinematographer um he is an
award-winning writer director who has
worked in shorts features and
documentaries Jeff's work has aired on
network television and PBS he is a
graduate of the University of Southern
California Film School and the LA
Stanford Meisner Academy originally
trained in scripted film making jav's
film The Buck and the rose was a
semi-finalist for the Academy Award for
best short film Jeff shot and directed
The award-winning short documentary
coaching curn about a young man with
fragile X syndrome which premiered at
the prestigious Big Sky documentary film
festival Jeff is a connectic artist
fellow and a film independent FASTT trck
fellow he freelances for disability and
social activist clients and teaches film
at Trinity College in Hartford
Connecticut and Jacob who is produ uh
Bria who is producer editor has edited
over a dozen feature documentaries
including the 2016 sundan special jury
Prize winner the bad kids and the
international theatrical hit lost in La
sorry lost in La Mancha fluent in
Spanish Jacob also brings experience
editing Multicultural stories such as
precious knowledge about Arizona's epic
battle to ban ethnic studies in public
schools and Beyond The Border masay
Laona about four sons from a Mexican
family struggling to overcome class
barriers in Kentucky Jacob has produced
two featurelength documentaries is an
associate professor at the University of
Arizona School of theater film and
television and is the author of The
Definitive volume on documentary editing
um so thank you for being here and um
you know I know the audience might have
some questions about what they just saw
on the screen so I kind of wanted to ask
some questions that were more about um
you know behind the scenes and the
process right of making a documentary so
um you know I'm particularly curious
about the various perspectives that you
manage together and throughout the
documentary these perspectives map out
the breakdown in state and federal
infrastructure and the varying roles
community members in Brooks County take
to fill in that Gap so how did you go
about establishing these relationships
with different members of the community
and how did this relationship how did
these relationships informed your
research process or what um ended up
making it on the
screen is this on yeah I'll say a few
things and then I can pass it to Jeff
and he can pass it to Jacob since um we
probably all have something to say about
this but um Jeff and I um began filming
this um in 2015 and I would say like the
first
year of filming was more research than
anything else because it was about going
to Brooks County and understanding what
was happening and forming relationships
with people there um and we um I think
the fact that the film is told in so
many you know different from so many
different perspectives one we we felt
that that was necessary to understand
what was happening there but also you
know we were just trying to figure out
what was happening there and to you know
for a long time and understand it
ourselves so I think in some way that's
reflected in the film that we have all
of these different perspectives but we
actually couldn't stop filming I mean we
we were so shocked when we first got to
Brooks County and saw what was happening
there and we were we we the film sort of
began as a different story a short film
about something else um and the within
hours of being in Brooks County we were
like okay this is
this the course of our film has changed
and we want to make a film about what is
happening here and just it was a
four-year journey of documenting from
all of these different perspectives
um yeah we kind of I mean we joked that
every time we went to to Brooks County
to film the ending got further and
further away and we kept bringing more
and more footage back to to Jacob and
sometimes people ask um
about the Vigilante group um as one
group that how did you get involved with
with them and um you know Kate and Eddy
were different they were kind of open
because they were used to talking to the
media but the and the Vigilante group
were would kind of wanted some press but
uh Michael Vickers would meet us out
somewhere and it took us about really
about three years of nagging him and
begging to kind of go on one of these uh
uh operations and so that was a process
and I think in I think each group had
its own process of building trust but it
was something that we kind of had to
kind of had to start with zero at zero
with and it was just by going back and
going back and going back and they would
see that we were shooting a lot of
footage and that we were working really
hard and I think that helped build the
trust and Eddie one said there's nothing
we wouldn't shoot so if that gives you I
mean we had a lot of footage and I think
some ways some of it
was just for our own purposes to get our
heads around what was happening even
though sometimes we knew okay this is
getting off track um it's still informed
how we understand what's happening and
and talk about now you know what's
happening in Brooks County so um and in
all of Texas along the border so yeah it
was a long long journey and uh the
footage would end up with me and I would
look at it um and we sort of tried to
start finding ways to take these some
you know in a way it's a series of
vignettes of different people and to
find a way to to put them together in a
way that you saw the experience of one
kind of refracted in the other in a way
um so you just spend a little bit of
time with the individual who's who is
found uh you know carrying a water jug
and we learn a little bit about him but
that maybe you know it fills in uh an
unex experience of what that might be
like right what what um what what that
part of the journey might be like for
somebody who you know fortunately is
found um and so you know we had by the
time we we came to further in the
editing we had two main stories and a
lot of these other little vignettes and
we just kept working until we could
figure out how to how to uh piece them
all together um and obviously it's oo's
story who kind of anchors it and his
brother and sister-in-law and family
kind of became partners with us uh as we
as we filmed and then also as we've
we've taken the film Out they've been
with with us uh to many many many
screenings talking about
it so one of the fascinating aspects
about your documentary is is a context
you know as you mentioned you started
this project in two um 2015 and it first
screen in 2020 um I think that it's true
in many ways not m not much has changed
but I also think the opposite is true a
lot has changed and you know between
Trump's 2015 promise to build the wall
and the drastic changes to immigration
processes um caused by the co 19
emergency um things didn't change so how
did the context and impact of the
documentary change between 2015 and 2020
as you know you went through this
process again I'll
start just keep passing in um so after
Donald Trump was elected um I think the
first thing we noticed in Brooks County
was there was more law enforcement more
board Patrol in FAL Furious and around
the checkpoint and that has all remained
um so that was like the most obvious
thing that changed
um and um I think you know it was
interesting because in the process of
making the film you know I I mean five
four or five years is a long time to um
make a documentary and I was like you
know we got to get this film out there
so it's still relevant like you know a
certain point like things become
irrelevant but but and and there's no
way we could have predicted um that the
situation now given um that 2022 was the
worst year on record for migrant deaths
along the US Mexico Co border it is
was um by the United Nations IO
International Organization on migration
um they um just came out very recently
stating that the US Mexico border is the
deadliest border crossing um land border
crossing in the world um and last year
was the worst year on record and I think
starting in 2015 I never would have
thought things would actually get worse
um and now with climate change um
and and you know one of the reason one
of the things we don't state in the film
about this situation is the reason why
people come in the hotter months um late
spring and summer and early fall um in
South Texas is because all of these
ranches are private and the um what's
happening on the ranches um is hunting
so migrants don't want to come during
hunting season which is the winter um
which would be much more Sean um but so
they come when they can and it's during
the hottest months and so every August
you know we predict there's going to be
media saying you know all about talking
about all of these migrant deaths and
you get a couple of Articles every
August late August and then it just goes
away for a year and then in August again
you see another New York Times article
Washington Post and then it goes away
and we've watched this for now now how
many nine years basically the same thing
and and nothing has changed except that
it's gotten worse in terms of the number
of
um remains that are found each
year I I don't really have a lot to add
to that except that um the people that
we've sometimes partnered with in the
Outreach and impact for this film like
the Washington office in Latin America
and other groups and NOS they're not
very happy with the Biden Administration
either um um because really as Lisa said
the net effect is the same really
there's not much change you know the
title 42 ended but there's a Transit ban
and these things haven't really
nothing's really moved forward in a in a
positive direction uh significantly I
think is fair to say well missing
persons act yeah the one thing is um
it's interesting because with
immigration you know you you you see the
headlines and there's a lot of um
partisan sniping then you look back at
what's been passed and it really
challenges your notion of traditional
left and right politics this this issue
of immigration um you know Reagan gave
amnesty and Bill Clinton as you know
from the film Now is really his
administration more responsible for
these deaths than any other and yet the
only president to ever signed a bill
that took any responsibility on behalf
of the federal government for these
deaths was Donald Trump
which he did with the missing persons
and unidentified remains act which he
signed um at the end of December at the
end of his term uh
so but you know really the problem the
death the death rate continues to climb
and it that's always been a constant
sadly so before I turn it to the
audience I have one last question so by
this point you've been able to screen
the documentary and talk about it across
different media media cost different um
audiences PBS podcasts academics border
patrol agents um has the documentaries
reception by any of your audiences
surprised
you do you want to talk about the Texas
tour yeah we um we've done a lot of
impact um a lot of many impact
screenings with the film um but one that
sticks out in my mind is um Jeff and I
during um the height of the pandemic
decided it was a good idea to do a tour
of Texas with this film we did a bunch
of mostly outdoor screenings like we had
a screen and a projector and we went
around
Texas um and one of those screenings was
in San Antonio and um the there were uh
some conservative people in the audience
who well I know that from just um the
the questions they were asking and prior
to the screening and um during the Q&A
uh this woman stood up and said you know
um this film really has made me think a
lot about some of my views on
immigration and um thank you so much for
telling you know bringing this story to
my attention and this you know is going
to you know give me some something to
chew on um and you know we
um we've been on conservative talk uh
radio with this about this film we've um
we have made a couple of trips to DC we
did a a senate hearing and a
congressional hearing we've um you know
we went to Cuba with the film we talked
to people who young people who are
thinking about immigrating to the US um
in Cuba um and it's all memorable
because this film it's just it's so
interesting showing different audiences
the the film and knowing that you know
we're all human it's it's um this is not
about politics this is about human
beings and everyone gets that and it
doesn't matter whether I agree with
their politics or not or grew up in the
same way that they did or not it we're
all kind of experiencing this in the
same way which is just shock and anger
and you know people ask what can I do um
so
okay thank you so much for that um I'm
now going to turn it to the audience um
we will have um someone walking around
with a microphone so you know you can
just go ahead and raise your hand and a
microphone will be passed to
[Music]
you
hi um thank you very much for this
really powerful film and it's hard to
even like ask a question I'm still
processing so much about it um this is
sort of out of left feel but something
um I've been thinking about a lot in the
context of my own work um with undocu
with with migrant people in the
Mediterranean context and I'm wondering
about the first the opening scenes of
the human remains made me think about
these conversations that are opening up
again regarding indigenous remains that
are hous in universities and I was just
thinking about this sort of visual
Archive of material that you have and
also
um you know both in the film and then in
excess of that and how you might be
thinking about that in relationship to
questions about remains about repat
ation about um um I don't know
accessibility of Mater like materials
for people in the future who might be
looking through that that sort of
material as well if that's something
that that you've thought about or has
come up at all for
you Leslie you're giving me more work
sorry um I don't
know I mean I do I do think that Kate's
Bradley's group uh operation
identification I I do think that they
they collect materials as they go
along I don't think we've ever gotten
that question it's an excellent question
I I think that there I could Envision a
time when um opid comes to us and says
you know we're starting a new project
and we're wondering if you want to you
know donate your footage which of course
we you know be happy to do I'm sure but
yeah I I hadn't really thought about no
thank
[Music]
you it's a really moving film and uh
thank you for making it uh I had a
question
about the water the the barrels of water
and where they were in relationship
to where people were where people went
missing
versus people who succeeded in getting
through when they took the what it was
it 14 15 barrels out they
disappeared um I was wondering if that
was also from the Vigilante group uh on
their land because I wasn't sure which
you you put the Mariposa Ranch and I
didn't know whose Ranch that was so I'm
just wondering
about where water didn't exist for
instance on that one uh
Rancher who said well I have the the
water source for his
cattle did the water barrels
help reduce the number of deaths in that
area uh so Eddie Canalis uh who is the
you know spearheads that project
although as you can see uh the other
Rancher who spend a tiny bit of time
with who claims credit for being the F
laer Durham he he also does this on the
ranch that he operates
um uh but Eddie Canalis uh figures that
they are useful because he does you know
replenish the water and some you know he
will they every so often they go out and
and and you know check them and there
are times when they've when the water's
been taken um and they will then replace
it so uh you guys can help me on this I
think it is really hard for him to be
able to document X number of lives saved
because how do you prove a negative um
yeah what about the reverse of that
where the bodies where more of the
bodies have been found is that where
there are no rain barrels because of a
Rancher won't allow it the the roots are
you guys should correct me on this but
um as you can see from that map that
shows up before they're doing that
search there are a lot of ranches some
of them are absolutely enormous the cage
Ranch is one of them uh and then there
are other ones that are relatively small
and it is kind of a patchwork of the
ones that are uh where where Eddie is
allowed where they say sure come and
come and do your work and and put your
barrels in the ones that he does not
have permission and I don't know if if
so it's sort of like the patchwork is is
a little too inconsistent to be able to
draw immediate conclusions like the one
that you're asking for um but I think
Eddie would probably say He he'll do it
regardless of whether uh you know
exactly what what statistics are are
shown or whatever and the fact that
there the water is being used clearly on
on at least some occasions is proof
enough to him that that's true and it is
true that that you know the inference
that that um Mike Vickers draws from
this is look they're on the on the
they're on the major routes and
therefore he must be in cahoots with
them uh they are on some of the major
routes uh so I I think it's fair to say
that they are having an effect exactly
exactly what that is is kind of hard to
to determine and and Eddie does use the
death mapping data to choose where to
put the water stations if a Rancher will
agree so and and of course this snake
bite and heat stroke and sometimes when
you reach that level of dehydration you
know the water may not help at that
point so or they may not find the
barrels or so forth and surprising and
surprisingly in the winter I mean there
are fewer migrants Crossing as Lisa said
for for that reason and we did do a
whole shoot with people who are out
there hunting uh which didn't make into
the film but uh there are some deaths
from a exposure in the winter uh you
know it gets it's rainy and it gets
really cold out there and can I say one
more thing um before the next question
um because I really don't want to leave
here without saying this um but
regarding your um comment about seeing
the maraposa ranch sign um I think that
might be the only Ranch sign we put in
the film and it just reminds me to say
that the um the Yale docu project
which is a um media law clinic took this
project on pro bono as um an assignment
in a course um and they went through the
film scene by scene and gave us legal
advice or sort of gave us um advice
about anything that seemed questionable
or could be
potentially uh problematic uh legally
and um one of the things after this
three-hour consultation very very
detailed consultation very scary
consultation um that we did was we took
out the ranch names for almost all the
ranches I think we had a bunch of other
signs in there and we took them all out
except for the Mariposa because we felt
that was part of the story like that was
necessary um because we kept going back
to that same Ranch and and people were
referring to the ranch so we left it in
we did get permission also on that ranch
um to film I think we felt more solid on
that particular Ranch the other ranches
um we got permission from the managers
but we learned that that's not enough
it's actually the owner that needs to
give you so in case you're ever thinking
of doing this there's a bunch of
documentary students out there um so I
just wanted to like give a shout out to
that clinic because that was a real
education that uh you know and it was
all pro bono and just amazing yeah we
owe them a huge debt they were really
wonderful and then the other part of
your question real quick is those those
barrels that were taken they were
outside the ranch Gates so those were on
a public road I mean it was out in the
middle of nowhere but anybody could have
just driven up and grabbed those and
Eddie has his suspicions which I will
not repeat but we don't know we don't
know where but it's not easy to take
them I mean they got to take those they
took the poles out of the ground and I
mean it would be very difficult to take
15 of those one
person there's a question in the
back thanks thanks for the um
opportunity to talk to you about this
this film
um um I have two two parts to my
question they're kind of different so I
just in the interest of time I'll just
put them both out there and then if
you'd like to um respond to either one
of them um one of them is about the the
making of documentary so my class at
wesle had the the opportunity yesterday
yesterday to hear from Jacob about um
the making of documentary and narrative
and narrativity I wondered um you know
on one level I wondered if in the
working on this film if it affected or
how it affected you're thinking about um
documentary as a media you know in terms
of um just any thoughts about that uh in
terms of the edits you're making and
then the choices the other question is
about the subject matter so I um direct
a center for the study of guns and
Society at Wesleyan and um you know I
was really struck by the scenes with
around hunting and I think this kind of
way that hunting and surveillance are
also getting closer together in fact I
think there was a court case about five
years ago where a ranch had to shut down
um because of a injunction because they
were using um what they were doing was
um encouraging kind of safari hunting
and hunting of w of animals on the ranch
property as a way to make money but
people could hunt from their computers
in New Jersey and so the technology of
doing surveillance at night for the
purpose of hunting and when you said
that in the winter the the migrants
aren't Crossing because of the fear of
hunting just also the scenes of the
animals I what I guess my question was
if I mean a lot you know given how few
of the missing people have been
recovered and mostly when they are the
finding is of De hydration but listening
to the um you know some of the Armed
Vigilantes and just tracking that a
little bit myself I was curious if you
or any of the people you talked with
there thought that there also is
lynching
happening do one of you want to take the
first question then I'll I mean the
second question then I'll take the
[Music]
first well there was there was a case of
lynching but I can't remember the
details do you remember the details of
that
um but I yeah I yeah I can't remember
but
um they the Vigilantes did run into some
problems be before we were filming with
them for detaining people which they're
not legally allowed to
do um so there's some question about
whether there was the camera effect with
us around and maybe they cleaned up
their act a little bit I was a little
surprised who those people were I mean I
thought it would sort of be any cowboy
with a gun you know and but they were uh
NASA Engineers they were retired judges
politicians and they would people would
come and spend their vacations sometimes
doing this um tracking migrants on these
ranches there was this there was this
weird sporting element to it and um you
know they were ostensibly trying to stop
traffic from coming through but if
nothing happened that night they were so
disappointed and that was just again
this this sort of this distasteful
sporting um vibe to the whole thing and
I mean they were also proud of of the
lives that they said they had
saved um in some cases because you know
as you can see if at that point you do
want to be found by somebody presuming
that they will end up returning you to
shelter and water and such um but yeah
it was It was a definitely a weird
vibe um and your first question was sort
of about making putting together
document the documentary and um you know
this is again this film is sort of a
it's an amalgam experience uh we we
stayed pretty close to the within each
of the two stories we we were very
faithful to I mean of course you have to
take creative license with with
precisely when you tell what but we were
very faithful to the facts as they
occurred um you know so you you you are
there the moment when Juan Jr was found
just like it's shown Etc but then there
are all the other little vignettes that
that play around in in there and so for
instance the the Vigilantes are out
there at night they think they see
someone the scene ends and then there's
just an interstitial moment where you
just see brush at night and then you're
in in the car with the sheriff's deputy
who finds someone on the road and there
was we had advice from someone like just
put those scenes right together they
make a call and here's the guy and he
comes out even though they were
different evenings and we had it that
way for a little bit and then we decided
Well that is pretty misleading um that
it didn't occur that way that night
right and that it doesn't necessarily
make that much difference in the story
so that was the reason why that that
shot is in the middle there uh which is
just a shot of things at night and then
we cut to a new scene and so it's kind
of ambiguous or I don't know you can
tell me how you interpreted it but we
invite the interpretation of look they
were out looking for someone here's who
here's who they found and yet we're not
directly saying that that is is what
happened but on an amalgam level that
that is what we're saying happens
because they are alleging that these are
terrorists and they're they're coming to
town to to overthrow the government from
the inside and our experience from being
there our meaning their experience
they're the ones who shot over over this
amount of time was that it's much more
if you had to put it into one story this
this you know Migel anill who was who
you know with the wet socks that is a
pretty typical event right that is the
kind of person who is found out there so
it's it's sort of choices like that and
then other choices where we were really
we wanted to make you feel like you had
been out there so there are moments in
which we that are scenes that are
relatively leisurely where where you
just sort of sit and you listen to The
Sounds um and that was really important
to us to feel like um you could feel
like like it might have felt out there
and they would come back talking about
the sounds of the brush um and that's
why we ended and we also like for
instance at the end we always assumed
there'd be an ending song we had but
money in the budget to to license
something we tried out I don't know how
many different songs and it never it
nothing ever felt appropriate and it and
there's a lot of music in the film um I
hope it's relatively subtle and such but
when we went to the credits it always
felt wrong and so we were like why do we
need music it's more much more
appropriate to just be out there in the
brush with those sounds and just let
them play it felt more respectful it
felt more appropriate um you know it
wasn't you didn't get like sort of a an
uplift moment but um well also it forces
you the viewer to continue thinking
about what you just saw rather than have
some kind of music be in your head and
you've moved on I think that's usually
with credit credit music you it's sort
of to kind of jolt you out of the
experience of watching a film and we did
not want that we want people to reflect
on what they just saw and and have all
of the emotions that one might have
after seeing something like this so and
we hope that there I mean we feel like
there is hope in the film there is quite
a bit of Hope with the fact that people
are out there caring as much as they do
and and you know spending you uh I don't
know there's we hope it's not as Bleak
as as some moments might make it make it
feel but um the but it also you know
like
to yeah it's it's a I mean it's a film
about death so yeah
um so I I have a question that came from
um a viewer on zoom and this is a
followup to the audience question so
they want to know who was your intended
audience and you know did you hope to
reach or challenge cons uh conservative
audiences or points of view with your
documentary um I'll start and yeah I
mean so we um decided to um get well
decided we were very lucky to get
funding from
PBS um toward the end of the process and
that means getting funding from PBS
means the film will broadcast on PBS not
HBO not you know and one of the um great
things about PBS is the audience is half
liberal half conservative and that just
felt like the right thing for this film
um so in terms of target
audience anyone that will watch anyone
that will watch and listen you know I'll
talk to anyone about this film and you
know so um usually like I always tell my
students like you need to have a target
audience like and I don't know
necessarily I mean we're just as happy
to share about this film with um a
church group as we are you know we
showed the film to boorder patrol
leaders um they weren't necessarily our
intended I wasn't thinking about board
Patrol leaders when we made this film
but certainly like in the back of our
minds like of course we want to show it
to border patrol leaders so I you know
did we have a target audience I mean we
did we did talk about making a 360
degree portrait of what was happening in
Brooks County we wanted to treat the
audience like intelligent capable of
making up their own minds about what
kind of policies should administer the
Border but in order to do that you have
to know what's going on you have to
witness and so I think sometimes we were
thinking we just just want people to see
this and I think we also felt that if
um if people could meet the families of
the missing they would feel differently
about the way we're administering our
border certainly lawmakers would feel
differently about the policies that
they're um and
acting you have a question back there
yeah I have a question it was an amazing
film you guys thank you so much for
bringing it here um I'm from Arizona so
it's very dear to my heart y'all are my
professor so you know um just seeing
this I I've spent a lot of time in
Douglas and so I'm very familiar with
the Border situation in Arizona um and
one of the things that I really
appreciated you guys doing was bringing
all aspects of how people become missing
whether that's you know death or
dehydration or the unknown and so I was
just wondering if you guys had any
stories I know that you guys probably
had a lot of different stories and you
had to be very selective of which ones
you included in the film but were there
any stories of people who were missing
and and were found or you know just in a
different state um anything like that
and and I just really wanted to also
point out um brick you already did that
that the ending was silent and just the
sounds of the of the nature I really
appreciated that um it was almost like a
moment of respect for the people who are
still missing or lost and so I just
before you mentioned it I wanted to
bring up that it was it was a very
beautiful moment and I really
appreciated
that
oh so my question was if you guys had
any people that we found
[Music]
yeah there were a lot we shot a lot of
footage so there were a lot of stories
you're right and there are uh you know
as the the title card says there have
been quite a few cases in which cait
Bradley's group have been successful
yeah they're up to a 100 so they passed
100 and you know one sort of interesting
thing is that actually the way that that
um that sort of process works of
recovery and uh and the coordination
between agencies and such is actually
much much much more functional in
Arizona than it is in Texas so their
rate is much much much higher uh the
kind of percentage of if you were to go
missing in Arizona uh and and die
whether whether you would your identity
would be found and and you know your
remains be reunited is is just um it's
just a different system Texas is highly
decentralized a lot of these counties
don't have much of a budget or much
expertise are not actually following the
law there's no coordination there's
confusion about responsibility and as
you hear in that story even sometimes
the funeral homes are kind of you know
you sure we'll take your money and then
we'll just pocket the money and you know
uh so there's it's a um and Brooks
county is now one of the better places
that in terms of the way it's run but
that's partly because of sort of you
know expose on previous practices so and
and the so in Arizona we've got a
medical examiner I live in Tucson
medical examiner and an NGO called the
calbri center for human rights and they
are in the same building and they meet
weekly and they compare the remains um
the DNA from The Remains and then the
phone calls from the families you know
DNA from the family members and they can
put these two things together and make
matches and they do and it's very
successful and and as Jacob mentioned in
Texas that doesn't exist um it's the
Wild West in Texas there's no
centralized system and one of the
reasons why we've been to DC with the
film was to get NOS like you know what's
happening at Texas State um funding to
do what they're doing they're you know
they're not funded by the federal
government they're they're writing
grants they're doing this work as part
of research at a university so that has
been um a goal One goal of this film is
to uh help them support them in this
centralized system um for Texas and in
fact um there were two more stories we
filmed that didn't make it into the film
one of them the F and both were
identifications that were done by
operation identification op ID and uh
one of them the family decided
um in the middle that they just weren't
ready which is understandable it's not
this is not for everyone um and the
other story I think we just couldn't
find a a place for it in the film it was
just it was a really complicated film
with a lot of stories and and it was a
complicated story it was it was it was
compelling it was a very compelling
story a sister had
um uh sister had died and then her
living
sister uh who was also
undocumented uh was kind of stuck
between what they kind of call two
borders you know the interior checkpoint
and then the US Mexico border it's an
area that sometimes is referred to as
the golden cage and she actually could
it was really sad she actually could not
go to her sister's funeral because it
was held north of the
checkpoint um where you know she had
known people and had there was family
and she was couldn't she was was afraid
to cross the checkpoint that had you
know resulted in her sister's demise of
course so um it was um it was just too
complicated to put in the in the and in
addition to that she was in a domestic
violence situation where she couldn't
leave this situation because she was
stuck between these two borders and
didn't have family around and eventually
I believe she the authorities let her go
to Houston because of the this domestic
violence but for years she was living in
this situation we met her we we talked
with her we filmed with her um and and
so it's like not you know like this
issue of these interior checkpoints they
have so many consequences um even Beyond
Death they create these situations where
people can't get medical assistance
people can't get out of an abusive
relationship people you know can't go to
a funeral it's like um those are just a
few things things
but and there's one question back
[Music]
here um thank you so much for this film
this was like um very hard-hitting and
and like beautiful um to see uh I have
two questions one as you mentioned like
you went there and you discovered for
yourself as well so like curious if you
could share a little bit about how it
evolved um over time and as you
mentioned you could take in some stories
but could not do the others um and the
second is how like you it's it's amazing
how you build those relations and that
trust with people right from the
authorities to the vigilan groups to
even more importantly the families who
like went through a lot of like turmoil
and it was not like a story for them so
curious about how you kind of um dealt
with that and also you must have like
shot so much like in the car and
everywhere like was there something as a
filmmaker that you were thinking about
managing like how did you manage filming
um like going out to the field of the
desert when they were like identifying
the missing people or like even the
different stories like I'm just curious
about how that process was for you I'll
say about the about working with the
family is just one anecdote and then
they can talk about what it was like
filming
the uh Omar and Michelle who are the the
married couple and it's his brother and
her brother-in-law who is missing uh
they found us so we had a website before
the film was done called missing Brooks
county.com and right around the point at
which of course it had been two years
all of this had happened and yet they
were sort of back to thinking no we
don't want to give up um Michelle
Googled missing Brooks County Texas and
she came up with our film and she just
wrote us on the little cont form and we
immediately put her in touch with Eddie
Canalis but we they were also about to
make a trip to Texas and they said would
you be interested in meeting with us and
they were they really were quite ready
they they were very much wanted uh their
story told and that was how that came
about it was a weird uh that's not we
weren't soliciting people or anything
but that that's how that story actually
uh that's how our involvement with them
uh
started and for the documentary film
making students out there um I see you
all um I have to be honest um when we
got that email from Michelle I was like
not another family like we're already
filming with two families and you know
this film is getting out of control
we've got the Vigilantes we've got the
you know and but you know you know deep
inside you have to explore every
possibility even though I was
overwhelmed by the directions that we
were going all the different directions
we were going in and
so we you know we wrote back and said
you know we're coming to Texas next week
like can we meet and we did and it was
amazing because I think very very
quickly we met in
Starbucks um we knew very quickly that
this was going to be a good match um BEC
I think in part because it had been 2
years it wasn't as raw as some of the
other
families but also you know we were
careful we were like look go back as a
family talk to your parents talk through
this see if this feels like a good thing
for your
family and like I don't know within
hours we heard back that they were very
much wanting to participate um and then
we just began filming probably the next
day um but um but my instinct at first
was like oh don't know you know it's
like like this is so complicated like
too many families too I mean we but to
you know to answer your qu first
question like you know we did we have
footage of other crossers that we you
know met that were that had given up you
know and from Honduras and you know all
over it just we have a lot of footage
that we never put into the film um and
so but you know just a word you know
just a lesson learned you know for
myself as well is that you you know you
need to pursue all different um leads
and see where they go as difficult as it
seems um because it can be very
overwhelming having hundreds of hours of
footage and knowing you know I'm come
from an editing background knowing that
someone has to like sift through all
this footage and make sense of it all
and uh so you know at a certain point
you have to discriminate yeah but it was
just it was Jacob so I was like okay
let's do it and I mean there are some
some some types of documentary films
that you really can research and
prosecute in a way that allows you to be
pretty targeted about you know you can
search out you know experts and to do
interviews and and uh lead people
through things in a way where your
research will lead you to what you want
to shoot and and it's kind of
straightforward and then there is sort
of the cinema ver ideal which is you
learn as you go and you shoot a lot of
stuff and you kind of make sense of it
as you look at what you've get GED in a
way it's a much more sort of far-flung
and organic kind of searching that
you're doing that you're living inside
of and that was what more interesting to
all of us even though it's it's uh it's
uh it it it it's it's harder to know
that that you're going in the right
direction or that uh you know exactly
what you're doing at any given moment it
it starts to become clearer as you start
to form conclusions about what it is
that you've shot and and in retrospect
like okay yeah it's a mosaic there there
are vignettes you know it sounds easy to
talk about but as you're making it it
can be um you are sort of struggling to
figure out how the meaning that you're
finding in it can be uh put together in
a way that that will uh Express that
kind of meaning U
so thank you so I think we're reaching
time I just want to say thank you so
much for this conversation and any last
remarks or anything that you want to
leave us with
I'd like to thank everyone who's
responsible for bringing us here a lot
it's
Teresa okay thank you so
much thank
Charlie thank you for those of those of
you who've join us online right now we
know there're those folks out
[Music]
there